[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird
and we search for the meaning of life
along the way presented by cass media
and soul pancake
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody i'm marine wilson
oh i'm sorry i'm russell ashland and
we're here
with metaphysical milkshake and um the
question today
oh it's a doozy wouldn't you say res um
is religion relevant is the question
wait a minute
raza you're muslim i'm just really
hungry i haven't really
and it is currently ramadan when we're
recording this
and you're stuffing your face with what
dude i totally forgot about ramadan you
don't forget about ramadan you can't
forget about ramadan
it's just been inconvenient okay i'm
going to be honest with you
i've been awake since like 5 00 a.m
because of my baby i'm starving
this is one of the pillars of islam
it's my least favorite pillar if i were
to like rank the pillars this one would
definitely be
at the bottom of the who who the [ __ ]
fast for 30 days who's got that
like i don't have that kind of energy i
have [ __ ] to do
well i'm baha'i we do it for 19 days
it's like ramadan light l-i-t-e
yeah no one beats us that's the thing
about being a muslim is that it's like
oh you do 19 days well we do
30 28 to take that but the early baha'is
did the baha'i fast and ramadan
so boom but i will say that this is one
thing that i that i just have to admit
is that i'm muslim a lot of people know
that about me
you know the older i get the the more
inconvenient
[Music]
this whole religion thing gets i mean
i'm gonna be
honest i mean i take religion seriously
you take religion seriously we take
religion seriously but
there's something about like whether
it's still relevant in my life that i i
notice the
older i get the less relevant it becomes
i mean have you noticed that at all am i
just talking to myself looking around at
like millennials who are leaving
organized religion
you know cheek by jowl it does seem to
bring up that question is there a
relevance to a
a belief structure that has
rituals and writings and um
activities and social events that one
needs to
to follow is that why do we need it
[Music]
is religion even relevant anymore i mean
i look i think
you're right that most people i think
would say that the the more you know
society advances the more we evolve the
more scientifically advanced we get or
or economically developed we are the
less
relevant religion is in our
society and it's hard to start to kind
of deny that fact right i mean
you just look around you you know from
the the the catholic
priest scandal to 9 11 you know we just
see
uh more and more uh evil
coming from religion most people would
say religion is the problem not any kind
of solution
you're a spiritual person we all know
that about
i dabble you call yourself a baha'i
that's a very specific
religious tradition so why
you know like why not like come to islam
islam islam is fun
we're all the rage recently did i say
rage rage was the wrong word
i'm not angry nobody we're all there's
not rage
the highs are cool i'm not saying the
baha'is aren't cool i'm just saying
maybe muslims are a little cooler
are you trying to convert me right now i
mean why not just kind of
you know pick and choose there are
things that i love about buddhism i
love me some baha'i stuff yep i love me
some baha'i
maybe like a little sprinkling of baha'i
there's some fun stuff about judaism
that i think is really great i mean
there's some cool things about islam
like why why pick one
why pick one nowadays well we have a uh
guest that might be able to answer this
question the incredible
actor and neuroscientist that's not
something you hear a lot
no no mayam bialik is here to answer
this very
profound question she was in the hit
sitcom blossom from 1990 to 1995
she's a vegan and verota vegan cookbook
she uh
was on big bang theory obviously for a
very long time amy farah fowler
she played that plus she currently stars
in and executive produces her own sitcom
called
call me cat on fox and all of those are
cool
but the reason we wanted to have her on
this show
is that she is by her own admission
a serious jew i don't mean
like the you know the kind of jew who's
like
yeah i mean i'll take yom kapoor off
sure you know i mean like
i mean like a serious jew like she takes
it
very seriously it is deeply a part of
her identity but you know i've heard her
speak
on her religious faith in the past and
it's really pretty profound
it's insightful passionate um
balanced uh i'm really excited to see if
she's got an answer
to this question why religion why today
is it still relevant
maya and bialik we are so excited
to have you on this show we have
actually been talking about this for a
long time
we talk about you all the time i talk
about you guys all the time is what's
funny it's very nice to be here
what a strange coincidence questions of
religion faith spirituality
uh loom large with reza and i uh it's
not
really what this show is about we we
dabble in those topics on this show
but you're one of the very few people in
hollywood
that is outspoken about your faith and
your religion and your belief and the
coordination between that belief and
science and um
so we're just super psyched to hear what
you're about
we know you've written extensively about
your jewish identity
reina and i just shared um you know our
uh i think testimony is what christians
call it testify
and testify baby we we we testified
um so yeah maybe if you don't mind just
you know for for
our listeners uh who are unfamiliar with
your religious journey could you just
kind of
tell us a little bit about it you know
tell us about your spiritual religious
journey
um was your family very religious yeah
i'm i'm ethnically jewish which means i
come from a line
of of people who trace their roots
thousands of years back
um to a people that has a historical and
spiritual
homeland as it were i saw those people
in that and that charlton heston movie
and they're running across from the red
sea exactly yeah that's exactly what we
look like you know the
the sweet story is that at some point um
my people spread out from there and
intermixed with all of the cultures
and and communities all over the world
um and i am eastern european
so i'm an ashkenazi jew that's what it's
called and
um that's my ethnic line that's not just
my religious identity there are i mean
it's a weird way to say it but there are
certain genetic diseases that that occur
in the population of eastern european
jews because of population bottlenecking
and the way that our kind of community
was structured so
even if you don't believe in god even if
you don't observe
religiously you still have an identity
as part of the ethnic line
of jews um you know i like to say
you know typically in college we are
tested for tay sachs and we're tested
for gaucher's disease and
even if you don't want to go to
synagogue you still need to get tested
for those things because that's your
ethnic line
so welcome to being jewish and they
shall know us by our genetic
they shall know us by the things that
happen because cousins that close
shouldn't marry
is really what it is growing up in los
angeles
there's a ton of jews and many people
think that we must own half this town
but jews are actually about two percent
of the united states population
and that means we're about like the
amish um yes we are loud
and we have our foot in a lot of
different arenas um and i studied
i studied judaism and and religion i
have a minor in hebrew and jewish
studies
from ucla along with my degree in
neuroscience so
when i left home is when i started to
kind of um
explore more and i got very interested
in the intellectual components of
judaism which i wasn't really raised
with you know i was raised going to
synagogue and
that was fun i was the kid who liked
hebrew school i went twice a week
i loved the songs it made me feel good
there was definitely something mystical
i felt you know i felt a
a resonant connection with something
that was indescribable
um but it wasn't really until college
when i decided to
try and find the people that i seemed to
be the most like
which was jews and you know it's kind of
embarrassing to talk about that because
i have white privilege and i'm aware of
that and there are
many jews of color but i have white
privilege to so to say that i felt like
i didn't fit in
can seem odd to some people but the
people that i most resonated with
socially culturally
uh happen to be the people that i found
in you know by and large in kind of like
the jewish organizations i you know
hillel is the egalitarian
campus organization i'm sorry like how
come why why do you think that is why
why do it's one thing to sort of
gravitate towards
people who have the similar interests
you know maybe similar politics or
whatever
but why someone who has a similar
religious identity
well because i think it's i mean for me
it's not just a religious identity it is
an ethnic
and cultural identity right so you know
the person i'm dating he's not an
observant jew
meaning he he has a tremendous sense of
kind of spiritual consciousness and he's
very jewish but he doesn't identify as
like a particular denomination
but there's a way that we speak because
and also we are both eastern european
you know um so there there is there's a
pattern of speech
that we have you know we are raised with
different kinds of grammar and
we have a structure of the world that
even if you don't buy into the religious
system
you have this vocabulary that is true
all over the world
you know wherever you find jews like we
have a we have a language of hebrew that
was actually resurrected after a
thousand years of not being spoken which
is pretty unusual
so we we have that in common it's a very
interesting kind of global
i'm gonna do the same thing with elvish
could sign me up for that you know as
for my spiritual journey
you know i the the jewish god is that i
was raised with is very
um it's very large it's actually
infinite
there's no end is one of the names of
god um i don't feel attached
to the notion that i have the right way
to know god
i don't feel attached to believing that
there's one way to know god
i believe there's a oneness in this
universe and it's the same as the
oneness of gravity
and all the principles of physics and
it's what makes the ocean be the ocean
it's what makes us have this
conversation that oneness is interpreted
very differently
by people all over the world throughout
time i've got one way
it's not the best way some might say
it's really not the best way
but i i don't i can't distance myself
from that experience of being part of a
divine universe
that i choose to acknowledge the way my
people have for thousands of years
but hold on a second because we we made
a giant leap here
you're talking about growing up with two
sets of plates and talking about your
ethnic heritage and cultural heritage
and wanting to fit in with uh
other other jews and find them because
those are your people and you
you feel a kinship um and now you're
talking about infinite god
but so many uh jews are simply cultural
jews and eat some matzo bry occasionally
and go to some high holy days
for you um there was a a point
at which you said uh no judaism is not
just a kind of a cultural
ethnic thing that i'm gonna kind of
dabble in i'm
buying into this god concept i'm going
whole hog
into this um faith
belief heart um i'm going to
connect soul to soul with my jewish
heritage
how and why did that happen so yeah i
mean
i i feel like because the concept of god
that i was
introduced to from the i mean my first
sentence was a prayer it was the shema
that says that
god is one that if there's anything out
there it's one that was my first
sentence
so the concept of god even though a lot
of it seemed
honestly silly a lot of the rules and i
have orthodox family and they dress a
certain way and like that seems really
weird
what i started realizing is that living
in accordance with those principles
brought me closer to being the person i
wanted to be
and for me and that's not true for
everyone but for me when i started
formally learning you know and and
judaism
you know they call us the people of the
book because we're super into our book
and all the things that come out of it
and that doesn't just mean we read it
and it's totally fine if people like to
read their book and
quote it to other people that's not what
we do with our book
what we do with our book is we take it
apart word by word
letter by letter and we find alternate
meanings and so it's a very intellectual
process it's a very cerebral process
that
sparked something divine in me meaning
it made me feel like
my brain was as divine as everything
else that i feel is divine
that's kind of i mean that's sort of
like the short story of how we got here
and i i added on more observance and
found that
it was putting me in a place where i
felt
grateful i was more mindful
you know part of the reason that we pray
for a million things all day is that it
keeps you in a
conscious contact with god as you
understand god
you know if when you wake up in the
morning the first thing you think is
thank you thank you for returning my
soul to me you know
and then you go wash your hands and you
say thank you
for this great honor of waking up and
being this person
who can go to the bathroom who can wash
their hands who can do these like
thank you for everything opening when it
should and closing when it showed that's
the prayer we say after going to the
bathroom
you know every every food has a
religious
you know has a religious consciousness
so we're
we're living in a world right now in
which um
religious identity is on the decline
and spirituality is on the rise
right uh anyone who studies american
religion
knows that the fastest growing religious
identity in the united states is the
so-called
nons or the non-affiliated they make up
about a quarter of all americans now
these are people who say oh no no i
believe in god i believe in a divine
spirit
i am a spiritual person but i refuse
to identify with a particular religion
right and you're doing the opposite
you're saying no no religion is the
thing that i identify with that's how i
express my
spirituality and so i'm curious like you
know
you're going against the trend is what
i'm saying that's that's me
it takes work i think a lot of people
don't want to do the work
they just don't like it it takes so it's
laziness that's why
people are saying spiritual but not
religious i i definitely think there's a
sense of kind of complacency
and a lot of people you know they they
want it when they want
it they want to thank god when things
good happen but when something tragic
happens
my faith is my faith does not waver you
know
i don't god is not my gumball machine of
like give me this parking spot
i want this i don't pray for my will you
know that's not a christian concept it's
actually a jewish concept
i pray for the will of the universe
which i choose to call god
but yes i like a place to go i like
ritual
i like a thing to do and a way to do it
right
meaning this is how we pray we bow here
we bow at the knees we
you know we do this our traditional
judaism is also
very consistent with my obsessive
compulsive diagnosis and i'm not saying
that lightly
we are a religion of what do you do here
and now
you do this you eat this you don't do
this here's the number
check it three times touch it four you
know like we we are an
ancient people that have a lot of
ancient practices which
can look very strange but there's a
rhythm to it there's a rhythm to my
calendar
i don't want to live outside of that
calendar my calendar in judaism is lunar
so like when i celebrate my hebrew
birthday that's exactly where the stars
were
the night that i was born you know i
celebrate my children's hebrew birthdays
in addition to their english ones
because it's a whole different identity
like
that's who i am and the ethics of the
teachings of judaism
while not uncomplicated have led me to
pursue the kind of things that sit right
with me
ray you know that i love me some magic
spoon
you know this i can't shut up about it
did you get your second crate of magic
spoon yet
i did get my second crate of magic spoon
yesterday thank you very much magic
spoon people
how do they do it because it's got zero
grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein only four
grams of carbs in each
serving and 140 calories per serving
it's keto friendly it's gluten free it's
grain free it's soy free it's low carb
it's gmo free
it's just not free free it actually
costs money but not as much money
as you think it does because we've got a
deal for you that's right you can get a
variety pack four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted
and peanut butter you can mix them
together you can mix cocoa with peanut
butter and
okay okay i think we've heard enough
from you listen folks it's real simple
go to magicspoon.com
milkshake grab a variety pack try it
today
make sure to use our promo code
milkshake at checkout and you save five
dollars off your order and magic spoon
is so confident in their product
it's back with a 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked or you just email me
i'll come over and i'll eat the cereal
for you
so remember get your next delicious bowl
of guilt free cereal at magicspoon.com
milkshake and use the code milkshake to
save five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this delicious episode
hey reza yes my friend i'm going to
bravely broach
a topic our show is sponsored in part
by blue chew blue chew is making waves
and bringing more confidence to the
bedroom by offering chewable tablets
that can help men get stronger and
longer lasting
erections heyo i have no problem saying
that
it's a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost blue chews
an online prescription service so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations
this is the awkward conversation we're
having the awkward conversation right
now reza
you don't have to do we're doing it for
you so that you don't have to do it
yourself
so if you'd like to benefit from the
extra confidence when it's time to
perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety
information and here is our special deal
for our listeners
try blue chew free when you use our
promo code milkshake
at checkout just pay the five dollar
shipping fee i'm sorry did you say free
that's bluechew.com promo code milkshake
to receive your first
month free that's a lot of erections
for free so many erections thank you
blue chew for sponsoring our podcast
[Music]
so there's meaning behind these rituals
and this one
to build community and uh
because the focus of this conversation
is like why religion why is religion
relevant why should one ascribe to a
set of beliefs as opposed to believing
in this crystal or that yoga class or
this dalai lama quote or
or whatever else kind of floats your
boat with a
you know podcast or what have you but
you know
uh reza did some uh delightful uh
studying here
and uh there are other benefits to uh
being
quote unquote religious um religious
attendance once or more per week
leads to an extra seven years of life
expectancy
says one study uh religious
participation by kids has been shown to
result in less juvenile delinquency
and drug use smoking higher school
attendance
um uh religiously active older adults
are 40
less likely to have high blood pressure
uh religious people report more
happiness and
score higher in terms of life
satisfaction
and people who go to religious services
at least once we once a week
may have a stronger immune system
um it's also been linked to an
additional seven years of life i think i
said that
so wait hold on wait wait as a scientist
though i have to say
that like there i could as a religious
person i could find something wrong with
each of those analyses because
there could be associations with other
lifestyle things that we're seeing and
also is this a white sample is it an
elite sample like are you asking poor
people in india are you asking rich
people in america
but yes yes also
religion does have some other benefits
because you want to see our sources
you're challenging our sources fine no
our source is the internet
okay psychology today episode 117
september 13th no but i'm saying it's
not simply
it's not because you believe it's
because of the things that happen
because you believe
right it's the people that you connect
with it's the sense of responsibility
it's when you show up they ask you oh
are you going to volunteer for this
committee to help feed the homeless
so your life starts building in
different ways when you're in that
structure
and to me that's what is shifting things
meaning
you know during during covid of course
religious communities rallied around
the older people and the the communities
in need
it's what we did i mean every week i got
another email from
my synagogue being like okay we're going
down here we're going to feed these
homeless people we're going to find
these people that need
and everybody was doing that because
that's the structure that facilitates it
meaning like i don't mean to be so
pedantic but
it means there's an email list there's
someone managing the email list
there's someone who's cross-referencing
oh which people like to help the
homeless versus which people like to not
interact with other people
and can they help you know pack things
before we send it out to the homeless
there's a structure for doing that and
i mean i don't mean to sound like a
crazy religious person but that feels
holy
i guess this is the this is the thing
this is the crux which is that
it's very clear what you um
mayam get from religion and i actually
really love the way that you were
talking about how
you know there's something to be said
about taking the hard stuff and the easy
stuff
right that you obviously you get these
benefits from from religion
and there are things in your particular
religion that you don't really like but
it's like well
i'm in it for the whole thing and i'm
gonna accept those things as well and
change the things that i can etc i think
all of that is lovely
that you know you pray um after you go
to the bathroom i also pray after i go
to the bathroom it's more like thank you
jesus more than anything else
like you know thank you guys wait you're
muslim you can't pray to jesus
just that one just after the toilet i
gotta say
for the record jesus might be feeling a
little left out here
we've got a baha'i a muslim and a jew
first of all
jesus gets plenty of attention he gets a
lot of coverage
uh jesus was a jew i think here's the
thing is that
the larger question is
why is religion still relevant to the
world
i mean there's something really
beautiful about the way that you're
talking about judaism particularly in
the way that it connects you to
this you know tradition that's thousands
of years old is people
triumphs and the tragedies and
everything that's involved in that
but like when you're looking at society
i mean
does religion at least nowadays does it
do more good in the world
or or is it more destructive in the
world
it's a conversation that i don't
necessarily feel the most equipped
to say like religion does more good than
harm you know i
i feel like you really could you you
could kind of go both ways
with it historically again my problem's
not necessarily with religion it's with
people
um and in particular religion has
i mean it's an understatement to say
that in the name of god
millions and millions of people have
died
um i think for me
the structure of my world means that
there's tremendous relevance to showing
up
there's tremendous relevance to
not throwing out the baby with the
bathwater and there's tremendous
relevance
to intellectually battling with yourself
and the world around you
and i want to understand things on a
very deep level
meaning i'm not saying i'm a deep
exceptional person i'm saying that for
me
i want to take everything apart whether
it's
love whether it's science whether it's
religion
i want to take it all apart and re my
religious tradition
encourages me to do that it teaches me
that we don't have answers we have
questions
and that's what i that's what i try and
bring
to my kids you know when i raise them
with this consciousness
that being said there's a lot of people
who do religion in a way that i don't
like
i'm just gonna say it you know i i don't
believe in a gumball machine god
i really don't and it's frustrating to
me when people say like well
you know he got better because i prayed
i prayed for it
it's like no you know my god is the god
of children getting cancer
you know and also the god of tremendous
glory and beauty
like god's not good or bad god just is
like do you say gravity's good or bad
it's good because it keeps us on the
planet but when it you know when your
cat falls off you know the tenth story
of a building
and it doesn't turn its head around
gravity's bad right
you don't talk about gravity like that
so to me
that's what god is and religion is the
place that i get to put that into action
it's what inspires me to do and if you
can find that inspiration
outside of of a religious structure
fantastic but for me i need to show up
every week
i need to know that my week stops on my
sabbath and i
unplug and you don't own me on that one
day and my
my religion is what gives me that you
know
i just want to say i love what you're
saying uh it really moves me and speaks
to me
um the co-producer of this podcast is
soul pancake a company that i founded
which was based entirely on the pursuit
and digging into life's big questions
because i felt like so many young people
were being so
kind of blase and non-committal about
why are we here
what's going on who the [ __ ] are we is
there meaning or is it all meaningless
like
let's dive into this stuff we don't i'm
not saying we're right or wrong or who
has the answers but
um that thirst for questioning
um which is interesting because most
people would say
ma and i want to hear your thoughts on
this most people would say religion
is gives you easy answers and is
not a mode or an impetus
to ask ever more probing questions
i can speak for my you know the the line
of thinking
that that i'm part of you know i'm i
i i i find that to be exactly the
opposite and that's what i was taught
you know by my rabbi in college his name
is robert heim seidler feller
he said many religions do stand on the
street corner and say like we've got the
answers come
we got it and and i come from a
tradition that says like we got
questions
you know and so you know for for me
my religious practice is living in
constant tension
constant tension with you know the
secular world in the religious world
with the concepts of good and evil as we
try and understand them
and also with understanding that being
human is incredibly painful
you know one of my favorite mystical
concepts is that you know in the
messianic age whatever that looks like
we will not be able to stop crying
because we will finally be awakened
to how tragic our existence is
and that it's only now in this era that
we live in
that we have this this protection from
the truth
which is that being human is so tragic
that we would
potentially weep all the time you know
and so for me that's kind of where i
live like i'm dust and ashes and the
world was made for me
that's a talmudic concept of that's how
you lead your day
that the world was made for you and also
you're nothing how do you live in that
tension
you know and for me the mindfulness that
my religious practice gives me
makes me feel like it's worth it you
know
and for my children i don't know if
they're gonna believe in god i have no
idea
what i know is that separate from a
notion of a dude in the sky
which is what many of us were raised
with there's a part of us
that has a desire to understand and to
have a connection with something bigger
than us
and and my mystical tradition that i
come from says
that's the way something unexplainable
is trying to have a relationship with us
it's how we're trying to understand the
universe
folks you know there's no better feeling
than learning something new i know this
i'm constantly learning stuff rain
you're constantly learning stuff it's
the spark of curiosity the thrill of a
new discovery and that's why
we love one dream video and audio
streaming
experiences created to blow your
minds one dream reza it's the coolest
place to nerd
out you can learn so much you can watch
it on your smartphone while you're on
the go
thousands of hours of content from
brands like the great courses
programs created in partnership with
national geographic smithsonian
history culinary institute of america
kino lorber
magellan tv and craftsy
with experts who know how to blow our
minds
and encourage us to celebrate our inner
nerd
you and i are all about the inner nerd
therefore oh yeah oh you're
all about one dream trust us your brain
is going to love this place sign up now
through our special url to get this
great offer
a 14-day free trial of unlimited
access go now to onedrive.com
milkshake that's
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m-onedram.com
milkshake rain you know that in my other
life i'm actually a writing professor
and uh let me tell you i am one of those
grammar nazis
like i am a real stickler
you don't have to tell me because i gave
you this essay i wrote on sacredness and
you marked it up from top to bottom
i did literally you're welcome not
everyone has a buddy like me
to fix your grammar and that's what
grammarly
is all about when it comes to saving
time working more efficiently
it's those little things that start
adding up and hogging time
in your day and what grammarly premium
does is it gives you real-time
suggestions
on your writing for people who don't
have me as a friend
so you can get to the next item on your
list in record time grammarly has
clarity suggestions so grammarly premium
helps you get your message across
quickly without repetitive or
unnecessary words it's got vocabulary
suggestions
with this free version of grammarly
you're safe from embarrassing basic
spelling grammar and punctuation
mistakes
and grammarly premiums advanced
time-saving features help you write more
clearly and
efficiently you can streamline your
workload with seamless integration into
microsoft office
your internet browser or your phone or
whatever else
you do your writing on so hit send with
confidence and get your point across
more effectively with grammarly premium
get 20
off by signing up at grammarly.com slash
milkshake that's 20 off at grammarly g
r a m a r l y grammarly dot com
slash milkshake and please for the love
of god
stop ending your sentences with the
preposition
and here's the kicker you're deeply
observant but you're also a scientist
you're a phd
in neuroscience your dissertation title
was
hypothalamic regulation in relation to
maladaptive obsessive-compulsive
affiliative
and satiety behaviors in prader-willi
syndrome
oh in fact that was my dissertation
title no way
i i mean it's such a weird question here
here maya is one of the biggest
holdbacks for people
around religion faith is a little
is related to religion but faith's a
little separate and that is
well you can't have faith you can't have
religion and
science coexist so it's not true
it's like people's favorite thing to say
because they don't want to be part of a
religious structure it's their favorite
thing to say
i don't even know if i know orthodox
jews who don't believe
in evolution you know what i mean like
if if you think that the torah is a
science book
i got a better science book for you you
know what i mean like it's not a science
book
no one ever said it was a science book
it's not supposed to be science book
everybody's okay with it not being a
science book that
that i interact with are there fringes
of people
like the schtissel people and the
unorthodox people you know
those are tv shows about you know very
very
cloistered hasidic communities that
everyone's fascinated with right
that's what's so fascinating is the
people who seem like they're from
another planet right
but that's a very very small portion of
orthodoxy and it's a very small portion
of judaism in general so for me like i
spend very little time
worrying about the veracity
and i think more about what it does to
me
what does it mean to me what does it
bring forth in me and how does it change
the way i interact with my fellow humans
like judaism is very this world what
happens here
we don't we don't have this notion of
you know another a redemptive place we
just don't
i mean it exists but like it's not for
us we're very much about
how do you act but so many people would
just say well let's just
we don't have to want to get into this
because it's a whole other podcast but
so many people would say well it begins
with god you can't
there's no scientific proof of god
there's no laboratory there's no
there's no computer experiment there's
no equation that
shows that there's some creator or
something like that yeah you have those
religious people like look at the human
eye
isn't that proof enough no i'm a
scientist that's not how proof works
so like i i i get it and
for me i don't need i don't need proof
i just don't i don't need proof of
this kind of being that i believe and
this is sure it's a cop-out but welcome
to being human
the concept of god that i have it's not
measurable
it has no end it's an infinite force
that governs
everything that we experience it's it is
it is in
every single breath we take not just the
jews it is a force it's
everything it's the force in everything
the force that through the green fuse
drives the flower blasts my green ages
my destroyer
says dylan thomas very nice
look at this i can quote he stole it
from rabindranath
but that's a whole other topic also a
whole other podcast
um but no for me everything that i
experience in the scientific world
is is evidence that i didn't create it
and i couldn't
that's divine to me yeah that makes that
makes perfect sense and i think a lot of
uh spiritually minded um
scientifically rational people would 100
agree with you but we're not talking
about reconciling
science and spirituality or science and
faith we're talking about
reconciling science and religious
identity and so when you were talking
about how
part of what draws you to religion
and particularly judaism and
particularly you know orthodox judaism
or a kind of orthodox judaism
is the idea that you got to take it all
like the good
and the bad the rules you like and the
rules you don't like and i
love that about that at the same time
though does that mean then you have to
take
you know the the non-scientific aspects
of the religion and the and the
scientific aspects like what do you do
with
you know did did moses part the sea of
reeds
did joshua stop the sun from you know
if i'm in 100 how do you then reconcile
that you know
so the the reconciliation comes um
comes in it's funny because rabbi david
wolpe who's um
a conservative rabbi you know like they
asked for his head on a platter when he
said it doesn't really matter if the
seas parted
and so i'm not going to say that it
doesn't matter if the seas parted
but for me my religious
my religious belief means we tell those
stories we take them apart and we talk
about them
and we get to take from them relevance
that
impacts our life and the meaning that we
have i don't
i don't live a life and i would say that
most jews don't live a life and there
are jews that do
but for me and this is completely
legitimate judaism that i practice
that's the thing like no one gets to
decide that my judaism is less
legitimate i get to say that i don't
know
there are things that i don't know and i
don't know that i'm ever going to know
if the sea of reeds parted it wasn't the
red sea it was the sea of reeds it's
much shallower so in theory like a
strong wind it could be a gale and it
pushes to the side
i don't know but the fact is we have a
tradition
that tells a story because it has
meaning
and that's the story in that case of a
deliverance from slavery and a birth to
freedom
that's a universal concept that we
commemorate
every single spring as our spring
festival
to talk about how we can help others who
are enslaved
and many many jews especially in my
community
talk about the palestinian people at
seders
and how p if if one of us is not free
none of us are free right
so to me that's where i put my focus
i and i don't mean to say like i have
faith i mean
that that's a story that we tell there's
myth in every religious tradition
there is storytelling in every religious
tradition
and i don't feel the need to hold that
kind of scrutiny
of i can't believe this story or i can't
believe the lessons of this story
unless i can prove that it happened
because you know what this is the best
story that i've got
and that torah for me that has got
everything that i need literally it's
got everything i need to learn
the lessons i need to learn to live the
life i want to live
and to be the human that i'd like to be
on a planet with other suffering people
well said beautifully said so i mean
this is
i think really instructive and
fascinating
um i think most people you know as
they're looking at
sort of where religion is trending uh
would probably agree that it's becoming
less and less relevant in society i'm
not sure if
i necessarily agree that certainly not
in the rest of the world maybe in the
united states it's becoming less
relevant
but i guess looking to the future
you know um of this country you know
let's let's keep it local
um do you still see a role
like a very a positive role that
religion can play
in our society despite all the [ __ ] that
you know it's done recently and and what
what is that what is specifically what
do you think the role that religion the
positive role that religion can play
in our society in the future could be i
mean i know it might sound
counter-intuitive
but for me the specificity of our
existence or identification
in a particular community also has the
ability
to to touch universally so
you know i i'm just speaking from you
know many communities that i know of in
my religious tradition
that have seized on many of the public
events of the last year the black lives
matter movement
you know getting getting coveted
education
and vaccines to communities that that
need them most
being of service to communities in need
and not just in our city but throughout
our country to me
that that kind of work is holy work
and it comes from the structure that i
tend to be a part of
um you know i i don't have this notion
that like
god's universal light will shine on all
people if
everyone just you know had a kumbaya
moment
that's not the reality of my religious
experience
the reality of my religious experience
is that we are all
doing our best in a world that shattered
a long time ago and all these shards of
light that we can collect as we
do good and and behave well
and help one another and treat others
the way we would like to be treated
those are the things that reunify that
divine spark
and that's a that's a kabbalistic uh
notion
but but to me that's what religion still
can and does do it still has the ability
to show you
how to be good to other people and i'd
like to remind people the old testament
is not the story of the jewish people
adam and eve were not jewish noah wasn't
jewish
it you know i don't learn just from a
jewish perspective
i try and learn from a universal
perspective and i would like to think
that all religion has the capacity to do
that and i don't like fundamentalists of
any religious variety i just don't
because to me that's not the world we
live in and that's like the wokeness
about me
you know and and the fact is i will also
say that
you know for my particular religious
identity it is tied a lot
to what's going on in our country
because friends of mine have stopped
wearing yamagas
because of our last president because it
was dangerous to do so
and that's very painful to me that i'm a
two percent i'm a minority
as a religious as a religious jew in
this country
and friends of mine who aren't even
religious are also falling under the
same scrutiny because they're just
jewish and that is something that's very
very uncomfortable
and i'm not saying that that's what
unites me with other jewish people or
what is the foundation of my religious
faith
but those are the places that i get to
have a structure to say
help me why what do i do and what
happens next
and guess what in judaism and in many
religions it doesn't always mean looking
for the answer
it means finding more questions
well miam now is the time for us to play
a little game
we call the lightning round these are
just like questions that we ask all
of our uh guests uh big
broad life's big questions and then you
just kind of answer with the first thing
that comes to your mind
what is something that no one knows
about you i'm a terrible nail biter and
always have been and my cuticles are a
mess i have gross hands
if you could be reincarnated as any
animal besides being a human what animal
would it be
oh gosh i like so many animals uh blue
whale it's my favorite
what's one eye opening experience you
think every person should have
therapy good therapy
name something that a lot of people like
but that you can't stand
so many things um uh romantic comedies
describe your soul in ten words or less
my soul is the thing that makes me get
up the tenth time after i've fallen down
nine
tell us one fact about the human brain
that would blow our minds
there's a part of the brain that if it's
damaged
you can't recognize faces you can
recognize
smells and names but you can't look at
even your own mother
and know that it's your mother it's one
region of the brain
what's one emotion you wish you could
better control i'd say
sadness um but also envy
what skill do you wish you had i wish i
could draw like for real
like like when i see things i wish i
could actually
make the thing on the paper look like
what i want to draw
not what a five-year-old would draw and
finally what is your life's big
question if not now when
miami alec this has been so wonderful
thank you so awesome
thank you so much it's been a pleasure
thank you
here's what i got from that conversation
okay
which i really like most people
when they say they don't want to have
anything to do with a particular
religion don't want to have anything to
do with that particular religion because
there's stuff in the religion that they
don't like whether they disagree with or
that
is hard or whatever i love how miami's
like yeah that's the reason
that's the reason you associate with a
religion
for the hard stuff for the stuff you
don't necessarily like
for the stuff you maybe don't disa you
don't necessarily agree with
there's something there yeah i love that
she's into the questions not the answers
and
into the wrestling with stuff and she's
got issues with some of the patriarchy
and some of the zionism
and some of the laws um
but she shows up uh that is a deep
difficult commitment and uh that is
very rare in the modern world and the
thing that she said at the end there
which i thought was so interesting but
also so
true about like the future relevance of
religion
is right that you know look look at the
situation that we're in right now
you know who's been stepping up to to
help
uh people deal with um you know the
problems of cova well it hasn't
been the government it's not really our
politicians it's
it's religious groups right who's the
first on the scene
you know in an emergency or a disaster
it's religious groups and so
you know whatever you want to say about
you know the historical
crimes of the world's religions and look
i'm a muslim so i
got very little to stand on here when it
comes to that
she's right that so much of the work
that is necessary to
build the kind of world that we all want
to live in
is being done by religious people people
who identify
you know with a particular religion
there's no way to sort of get around
that
now i think a lot of people listening
are probably like this is [ __ ] i
call [ __ ]
you got two religious guys interviewing
a religious woman about how great
religion is
why couldn't they get a skeptic um why
couldn't they get an atheist
uh someone to lambaste her and skewer
her and in
you know and i get it and and and i
accept that i'll i'll go along with it
but i agree
reza i think that i think it's easy to
kind of
whole cloth discard an entire belief
system
and to question its relevance but the
thing that most struck me
was um community coming together
in service towards some higher purpose
bigger than ourselves some greater
mystery
and that really touched me about her
faith
and her religion and i think she's onto
something
we actually got a lot of uh calls on
this topic
apparently people are very interested
about whether religion
is still relevant who knew this one is a
good one this one is uh
johnny johnny's got a comment about this
topic hello rayne and reza
and johnny from sweden here i think
religion is still very relevant because
the human
is a spiritual creature and
the human being need to fill that void
inside of them
uh we really need to believe in
something uh
because if we don't the life on this
earth
becomes less meaningful if you know what
i'm saying
so religion is very very relevant today
i know what you're saying for those who
believe
in the gospel of jesus it's real very
much relevance
um so that we can
be saved you know and uh if we think
about just
to fulfill that void inside of us that
needs a spiritual
guideline uh it's very relevant for our
mental health so
yeah that's what i think all right wow
we got
one of the 17 born-again christians in
sweden
to call in that's that's
what do you think take away the whole
like you know
salvation from jesus part of it which i
respect but
you know you and i totally agree with
what he said we are
fundamentally spiritual beings right
we're not we're not sort of
spiritual beings inside of material
bodies where
you know we are in and of it of
ourselves like the way that we are
constructed you know we we are we we
have no choice but to sort of strive
towards transcendence and however we can
find it so yeah i mean i i totally agree
it goes to my favorite quote
uh the great father
jesuit priest philosopher said we are
not human beings having a spiritual
experience
we are spiritual beings having a human
experience
and i agree with that completely
you know when i am
feeling frustrated lost and uh anxious
angry confused when in my meditation
um when i come back to this idea that i
am a spiritual being
having a human experience all of a
sudden the clouds lift
and i'm i'm much more able to have kind
of meaning clarity focus
in my life yeah and look at you know
religion can be a very helpful way to
help you
make sense of that spiritual longing
that spiritual
desire but yeah we're we're on we're on
the same page with you
johnny from sweden and you know listen
rez i think you and i are both
uh maybe we're in the minority of the
podcast world or these even metaphysical
podcast listeners
but you know religion gets a bad name
these days a bad rap and it should
for so much of its nefarious activities
but
i will say that one another thing that
religion
not just spirituality gives one is
community and it's something that
humanity
desperately needs and it's a it's a
community that's broader
than your own tiny little tribe of
people that just kind of look
and act and talk and walk like you um
it can have a much broader scope than
that and maybe
religion can allow us to have a
continuation of that community to
embrace the entire planet
call me a dreamer call me a dreamer
listen i absolutely and i think mayan
would agree
absolutely but we've got another caller
res brennan
has got something to say on the topic
let's hear from brennan
hey guys i just wanted to kind of speak
on the is religion still relevant
um i really do believe that religion
should be still relevant because
spirituality
is religion in its own sense meaning
like
you can believe everything is
intertwined and interconnected together
like all of us are intertwined together
within ourselves and within the things
we do the actions the
schools of thought is what keeps the
world going round
because you know people sitting around
like random
inert pieces of junk not doing anything
you know no offense to people that do
that hate to each their own
but you're not you're not fully
unlocking the powers in which
your mind withholds if that makes sense
you know like people that are actors are
are generally whether they like it or
not
spiritual people unless you go into the
dark side of hollywood but still
a completely different scenario
i believe that religion
is still relevant maybe not radical
religion
that should that shouldn't be the thing
but actual religion yes
and also
did he just say end also and then it was
it
[Applause]
i don't know what brennan i want to know
what the dark side of hollywood is
because
i want in
that's what the money is sign me up what
is the dark side of hollywood he's
referring to
lee real man i think he's talking about
the scientologists
like we we we agree that we are
spiritual beings having
a human experience
but again i would say that it's it's
integrated that we it's not
that these are separate things right the
sacred and the secular
uh that we in just how we are
made are meant to live life in its
fullest expression while
recognizing that there is more to
the experience of being human than the
material realm
there is more to reality than the things
that i can experience
just with my senses that there is
something beyond
this and that the the human condition is
about
striving for that thing and as we
already said religion can help
in that striving it can sometimes hurt
but
for the most part what it comes down to
for me and i have a lot of eight close
atheist friends and i get i get where
they're coming from
completely um and i love a good atheist
i really do i love me a good atheist
don't you rezza
i it depends on the atheist
but for me and this is something that i
experienced as a
teenager growing up like the world the
universe
makes no sense to me that somehow or
other through an accident of molecules
and evolution and dna that i have this
rain wilson consciousness
and that i've had you know i've heard
symphonies and i've seen radiohead live
and i've fallen in love and i've had
struggles that it's just
a random assortment of electrons
bouncing around in my head because i'm
basically a monkey with a bigger brain
and then
my consciousness snuffs out like a
candle and then that's all there was to
it
that there's nothing behind all of this
stuff matter energy life memory
it just doesn't make any sense to me and
but you talk to some atheists and
and they say conversely it doesn't make
any sense to me that there's
something beyond all of this materiality
thanks for listening uh please leave
your comments
on at metamilkpodcast on twitter
write us and follow us me rayne wilson
and reza aslan
on instagram we're at metaphysical
milkshake
and we'd love to hear from you we love
utilizing your
questions and comments on the show and
maybe we'll even bring you on board and
interview you
and we're going to make you a big big
star baby big big star and introduce you
to the dark side of hollywood
my name is reza aslan and i'm rayne
wilson
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson
it is produced by safa samazadeh yazd
harris lane
mick dimaria hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold an audio
mixed by justin kyle
original music by jeff tang
there is a ritual jewish divorce it's
called a get
and it is a profoundly spiritually
moving experience
so jews have been doing conscious
uncoupling thousands of years before
gwyneth paltrow
that's a million percent true
you